what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to the rumor roundup our
weekly series where we cover all the
news and rumors that you may have missed
over the course of the week and it's
halloween that time of year when we let
our children collect candy from
strangers in the hopes that they won't
poison them and we have
that's pretty dark man we have an
interesting episode today one because
the news is kind of limited but we also
have some pretty interesting
announcements for you guys and hopefully
you guys can understand me pretty well
fingers crossed i guess we'll have to
wait until post to find out whether or
not the audio works so let's start with
the big talking point that everybody's
bringing up this week which is that
eternals has a 60
on rotten tomatoes which makes it the
worst reviewed marvel cinematic universe
movie since thor the dark world and this
is interesting right because we're
seeing reviews coming from different
directions there are people who on the
negative side are saying the movie's
overstuffed they're saying the cast is
forgettable and boring they're saying
that the film's just way too complex
that it's the worst marvel movie in
years and then we have people on the
other side of the equation saying the
film is fantastic there's a lot of
history there there's a really
intriguing piece of cinema that will
establish the marvel cosmos and people
just can't quite appreciate it yet and
regardless of which side you sit on i
think we can all agree the movie seems
to be pretty polarizing now we do have
to include here apparently what's been
going on is people are saying the
movie's been review bombed by people
saying that there is a gay kiss in the
film people don't like that but if i'm
being honest with you guys i think
there's a couple reasons why this film
is not really receiving the kind of
welcome that marvel cinematic universe
films have received in the past
especially considering this is the first
film of its kind that we're getting and
i think the first thing has to do with
the nature of the characters in all
honesty as a guy who's been reading
mobile comics for 25 years one of the
things that i've learned is that by and
large
no one cares about the eternals
[Laughter]
they're like the inhumans they exist but
no one cares that they exist largely
because the nature of the eternals is
such that their role isn't really
necessary that in marvel comics the
eternals serve as what is kind of a
protector of the human race and they do
that at the demands or the orders of the
celestials but in the face of teams like
the x-men and the avengers and alpha
flight and fantastic four and excalibur
and the list goes on and on and on big
hero 6 which was a comic book superhero
team from marvel before it was a disney
movie which was actually a pretty great
film
there's a lot of heroes out there that
exist to protect the world so you don't
really need the eternals and that's the
biggest issue that you've had in marvel
comics over the years is that the
eternals just really seem unnecessary
they just don't really matter at all and
that's the reason why if you go and you
look over the history of the eternals in
marvel comics you do have the old jack
kirby stories which were interesting but
by and large if you asked me rob what
eternal story should i read to get ready
for the movie i'd say read eternals vol
1 by neil gaiman issues one through
seven even though it was supposed to be
six and then follow up with eternals by
charles noff which was actually an
immediate follow-up to neil gaiman's
story and that one lasted nine issues
and then you're done never read anything
from the eternals ever from anybody else
because it doesn't matter i mean you
could read kieran gillan's run right now
but in reality it's too early to know
whether or not the run is going to have
any major meaningful impact on marvel as
a whole it's cool in terms of the story
but the point that i'm getting at here
is that the marvel cinematic universe is
making a movie about characters that in
the comics don't matter and in the
comics audiences don't really care and
so it's hard to take a character or team
in the comics that no one cares about
and then throw them into the mcu and try
to get people to care about them now you
could point the figure at iron man and
you could say iron man was a super
obscure character before he was made
into a movie that the marvel cinematic
universe had to actually convince people
that he wasn't a robot before the movie
was made but in all reality iron man was
hugely popular for comic book readers
who were reading marvel comics civil war
force works all kinds of different
things made iron man a prominent
character people outside the comics just
didn't really know who he was but again
no one who reads marvel comics really
cares about the eternals so it's kind of
hard to make people who don't read
comics interested in the eternals now
again this is rotten tomatoes right so
these are people who believe that movies
are inherently works of art in which
case i don't know how you explain
frankenfish but the important thing is
that these are a select few number of
people so when you go into the film
ignore the positive reviews and ignore
the negative reviews just watch the
movie and make your own determination on
whether or not you enjoy it i'm
certainly going to be doing that the
other reason why i think this movie
might be struggling is because if you
look at the history of earth in marvel
comics even only including the
celestials and leaving everything out
including like the demigorge or demiurge
if you want to call them that uh cathode
and like sidorak and like all these old
monsters and beings shumagorath who rule
the earth at one point in time you focus
only on the celestials that's still a
lot of history there and that's still
complex way more than you can really
cram into a two and a half hour long
movie especially when you condense it
down to what will most likely be a 15 to
20 minute explanation if that and expect
people to be able to walk away fully
comprehending what they're seeing that's
a tall order right i firmly believe that
like the history of earth in the marvel
cinematic universe
should be a series that's released on
disney plus i've been saying that for a
long time right i mean we did a history
of the marvel universe and just the
segments on earth alone took us about an
hour to do it's just that much going on
there so again it's one of these things
where it could be just a scenario where
they try to cram too much into a
singular film at the end of the day we
won't know until we see it but i don't
know i'm gonna go into it with an open
mind i'm not gonna worry about any
reviews on rotten tomatoes i usually
never do and then just kind of make my
own determination from there now the
next little tidbit here is actually a
really entertaining piece of news
apparently all you guys out there who
are just really excited for the
spider-man no way home trailer the final
trailer are just like review bombing
everything that sony releases that's not
the spider-man no way home trailer in
the sense that like if it's not the
trailer it just gets massive amounts of
dislikes
i mean in reality let's let's kind of
put this on the context in reality
sony's a huge corporation and so likes
and dislikes on their various videos in
terms of the youtube algorithm don't
matter when you become a youtuber one of
the things you learn is that one likes
and dislikes don't really matter all
that much and two what little effect
they do have on a video doesn't apply to
major corporations they kind of get
special treatment right they can kind of
do whatever they want to because they're
major corporations and they just give so
much money to youtube right so rules for
the not for me it's kind of how it works
when it comes to corporations and
youtube as a whole that said it is funny
because it's the digital equivalent of
all these people sitting in like a
restaurant waiting for food not getting
it and then just like stomping on the
table and chanting food food food that's
basically what this is i think it's i
think it's kind of funny right i mean
once you step back and you realize it
has no real bearing on sony it's kind of
funny you know i think it's entertaining
at the very least uh it is people just
kind of voicing their desire to sony
whether or not sony will listen i don't
know i imagine that trailer is already
on youtube and it has been for a while
and it's just scheduled we're just
waiting for the day when it comes out
because it's scheduled to come out on
that day in truth what sony's actually
doing and this kind of segues into our
next thing the trailer for mobius the
new trailer anyway according to daniel
rpk as you guys know the guy whose leaks
and and all that kind of stuff always
usually proves to be accurate that
trailer is supposed to come out this
coming tuesday at the time we're
recording this video
if that really is the case it's a smart
move by sony and the reason why is
because we know mobius is basically in
the mcu from the first trailer that we
saw where you basically had the graffiti
that pointed that spider-man was
essentially a killer that kind of a
thing so obvious references to the
aftermath of spider-man far from home
and the death of mysterio i imagine a
lot of people will go into the mobius
trailer looking to see little easter
eggs wondering if there's going to be
any kind of involvement or exploration
on what we already know in terms of its
role in the mcu as it relates to
spider-man so while it's not a full-on
spider-man far from home trailer at the
very least it does give us at least a
kind of tease or at least something to
kind of keep our appetite slightly
satiated as we wait for a new spider-man
trailer that said i do think it's going
to get disliked all the hell because
it's not spider-man no way home
and it's actually a trailer for mobius
instead of spider-man no way home so
regardless i think it's still going to
get hammered but i think it kind of will
quell people a little bit not only that
the important thing here to understand
when it comes to that movie is one it's
kind of the forgotten mcu film right a
lot of us i imagine forgot that mobius
was coming out last year i personally
didn't i've been looking forward to it
just because of the fact that the
introduction of mobius along with the
reworking of blade as well as the
possibility of ghost rider being thrown
into the mcu the details on that is
pretty scant we don't know if it's going
to be like danny ketch or johnny blaze
or or robbie reyes or whoever i don't
even think there's any casting
announcements or anything i think it's
just one of those somewhere along the
line it will be coming but we are
getting like werewolf by night we had
doctor strange the stage is set for the
midnight suns and so i'm really really
looking forward to that and mobius is
just one of the pieces of that puzzle so
i didn't forget about the film but i
imagine a lot of people had and so sony
throwing out the mobius trailer before
they released the trailer for spider-man
no way home is smart because right now
everyone's eyes are on sony's youtube
channel waiting for the release of
spiderman no way home so even if mobius
gets a bunch of negative attention any
attention is better than no attention so
i think it's a pretty smart move for
them to go that route in terms of
releasing that trailer before they
release spiderman no way home but as the
final little tidbit here for this
episode before we get into some really
important announcements regarding hiring
here at geek culture explained and
comics explained as well rumors are
circulating around about this idea that
dr octopus somehow managed to get his
hands on stark tech and that that's
actually seen in a lot of the stills
that we have from spider-man no way home
when he's fighting spider-man that his
tentacles are basically the same color
as the iron man suit now as you can
imagine this is both excited people but
also kind of irritated people a little
bit and the reason for this is because
people are excited at the possibility
that the legacy of tony stark lives on
the dr octopus somehow managed to find a
way to use stark tech to either create
tentacles or to enhance tentacles but
for the people who are a little
exasperated here i understand where
they're coming from because this idea
seems to hit on the notion that like the
mcu just cannot move past iron man right
that everything somehow ties into the
legacy of iron man now i think the
legacy of iron man is important i think
the idea of tying back into the things
that iron man has done over the years
and how his impact on the mcu still
continues on but i do understand the
idea that like not everything needs to
involve stark tech or iron man in some
form or fashion now having said that in
terms of the tentacles themselves a lot
of theories have come out about this so
on one side a lot of people are saying
that when it comes to the tentacles of
dr octopus being based on stark tech
that this is an indication that otto
octavius has been in the mcu for a while
that either he lost his tentacles when
he was brought into the mcu or somewhere
along the line they were destroyed
deactivated or you just simply just cast
off the old ones and created new ones
using star tech it's a cool theory but
honestly i think it's a little too
far-fetched given the context of the
film at least as we understand it the
more plausible theory here is that the
tentacles themselves are the result of
dr octopus basically fighting spider-man
when he has the iron spider suit and
then stripping the suit away from him
because it's based on nanotechnology and
then incorporating the the
nanotechnology of that suit into his
tentacles so quite literally he's got a
hold of peter parker the suit leaves
peter parker's body bonds itself to his
tentacles and that's where you get that
shot from honestly i like that theory a
lot more it makes a lot more sense and
it actually brings everything full
circle and the reason why is because it
allows peter parker to leave the legacy
of iron man behind that when you look at
spider-man homecoming that came off the
heels of civil war so in a lot of ways
both spider-man's appearance in civil
war and the film homecoming itself was
really him just kind of being tutored by
iron man taught what it means to be a
superhero in that kind of thing when you
get to far from home that's the
aftermath of iron man dying so a lot of
the scenes that we saw with spider-man
during infinity war that kind of led of
course into him basically disappearing
but coming back and having to deal with
the idea that his mentor is essentially
gone so we had to kind of stand on his
own two feet and understand what it
meant to really be a hero absent the
influence of iron man you get into no
way home and i would imagine this is
really just peter parker kind of
becoming his own hero now right leaving
the legacy of iron man behind walking
away what better way to to fulfill that
idea than to remove the iron spider suit
from spider-man thereby removing the
last will and testament that last little
tidbit of the iron man legacy from peter
parker and throwing him into the role of
fully becoming his own spider-man right
the blue and red iconic suit this would
be doubly more important if we got
something akin to brian michael
bennett's spider-man right that story
was a story where miles morales was
spider-man in the ultimate universe
following the death of that universe is
peter parker and then peter parker from
the main marvel universe met miles
morales and said i give you my blessing
of spider-man that tom holland fully
becoming spider-man comes by way of him
meeting toby maguire and andrew garfield
and between them it's all kind of like
yeah man you're as much as spider-man as
we are be your own guy do your own thing
be your own hero and that solidifies tom
holland as the spider-man that we know
and love going forward into the future
of the mcu or if that doesn't happen in
the rebooted sony verse featuring those
spider-man films so with all that out of
the way and as mentioned previously
i am looking to expand and i'm hiring
people here at geek culture explained
and also what comics explain i'm
actually hiring for a few positions two
positions really the first one is for an
anime
manga podcast so if you live in the
northern colorado area so like fort
collins longmont greely then check out
the link in the description which will
send you to the application form for the
anime manga podcast here at geek culture
explained now if you don't live in
northern colorado that position is not
for you
but the position that congress explained
might be so i'm looking for a writer
researcher for comments explained
podcast so if that's interesting to you
make sure you check in the link in the
description for that application make
sure you fill them out and that's all
you have to do just hit send when you're
done and they'll automatically be sent
to me i will comb through them and if
i'm interested in bringing you on then
we'll go further from there i'll talk
about the pay and all that kind of good
stuff so you kind of know what you're
getting into so with that being said
guys hopefully i hear from you thank you
all for watching and i will catch you
all later
peace